[Musik]
vielleicht doch nicht so nach 15
politiker ihr büro für empathie hätte
gewisse sensibilität warten auf den lift
nach oben in die sozialdirektion der
stadt biel
dort wo ihn kaum einer haben möchte doch
dieser mann hat aus warum bleibt einer
wenn er nicht willkommen ist
davon handelt dieser film meine suche
nach einer antwort beginnt hier im 13
stock
[Musik]
das ist doch das ist schwieriger ist
modell sprechen aus atom dass diese
sprüche wenn er fordert ein bekenntnis
ja also das vgh kleine gleich um die für
ihn zählt gleich dom gleich keine
konzept das die so fordert oft begegnen
vorurteilsfrei bin auch ich nicht
svp direktions vorsteher wertvoller sei
ein mann der widersprüche und voller
überraschungen bund so umschreibt er
sich selber naja bei unserem ersten
treffen empfinde ich die atmosphäre in
seinem penibel aufgeräumten büro eher
steif und verkrampft
das ändert sich schlagartig aus teurer
und spontan auf ansprung zu sich nach
hause einlädt
bereits im eingangsbereich die erste
überraschung
svp-mann feurer rede tamilisch und halt
das haus mit einer familie aus sri lanka
er selber bewohnten unteren stock bis
vor kurzem lebte der 54-jährige hier
zusammen mit seinem freund einem
25-jährigen mann albanischer abstammung
für mich schon wieder eine überraschung
wo die liebe hinfällt sofas kommentar
dem gibt es wenig entgegenzusetzen
die show ist die liebe meines lebens sie
und das sehr intensiv und das macht ein
büro das macht schon das geht ja wenn es
nach einer zerschlagung
ich gehe zwar im park nicht mehr hell
malige partner was macht also der
gedanke da ist da ebenso 420 stellen
kleines läuft ziemlich das ist dale ford
von ihm abschied dass sich da einer das
bett sondern daher und da auch täglich
im moment schlafzimmer zwischenzeitlich
haben es die beiden noch einmal zusammen
versucht doch das liebes-comeback sei
gescheitert
wir folgen wertvoller an die
stadtratssitzung dieser hat bereits
begonnen
ist das gut wenn ich jetzt tamilische
mitbewohnern schwul
ein touch exotik trotzdem wieder rechts
und nett und das versprechen die
rekordhohe sozialhilfequote zu senden
das zog die bieler welten feuer in die
exekutive ihrer stadtregierung und da
ist er nun seit gut zwei jahren in der
höhle des löwen ein gefundenes fressen
für gegenspieler ein außenseiter
wirklich angekommen im politbetrieb
stand feurer nicht er habe mühe den
privatmann und den politiker feurer zu
trennen wurde die maßnahme da musst du
dir brachte bewies muss neben ihm
starker husten
wie macht feurer seinen job ich frage
anwesende stadträtinnen und stadträte
anderer parteien nach ihrer meinung
egal ob links oder rechts diesbezüglich
herrscht einigkeit versuche abzweigen
das ist eine enge h gut machen gewesen
auf dem waffen eng genau wo das spürt
man
und das ganz große schwierigkeit wenn
man irgendwas
jetzt ist finito jetzt macht das sehr
sympathische türkische tolerant aber
natürlich die härte was brauchte dann
business line ich jetzt sagen wer da
drin für die für ihn sprach wen würden
sie mir wahrscheinlich vor der svp
und so startete mainz sind immerhin 650
[Musik]
rückhand darüber werde ich mit vorreden
vorerst aber privates eine
wohngemeinschaft zwischen tamilischen
teenager deren mutter und einem svp
politiker der in ausländerfragen streng
auf parteilinie ist das wirft fragen auf
im taxi fuß wenn wir noch ein buch das
ich mich sehr sehr wichtig das ist sehr
praktisch ruppel gebot habe ich sehe was
ich geboren wurde hatte joshua zum
durchbruch noch nicht ob ich hab ich
gesagt wie es hängt also habe ich die
vorstellung eigentlich in ordnung ist
[Musik]
wie wertvoll zu seiner tamilischen
familie kam ist eine längere geschichte
die verkürzte version beginnt mit
vollgas reise durch sri lanka dort
lernte er den vater der kinder kennen
als dieser in die schweiz flüchtete samt
eurer ihn auf es kommt die frau dazu
nach und nach die kinder nach der
trennung der eltern entschied sich
feurer weiterhin für die auf sozialhilfe
angewiesen familie zu sorgen für ihn
sicherlich auch eine chance auf
familienanschluss und halt etwas macht
mich stutzig wie kann jemand der
sozialhilfequote den kampf ansagen
während seine mitbewohner von den
leistungen profitieren dass sich für
kranke muss man ansetzen wo sie problem
einfach sagt er stehe ich jetzt zweifelt
frauen also zuhause beziehen sondern was
die problemlose keynote bereitet sich
vorzeitig fordert und darauf setzte für
server und das ist uns ganz bevor sein
engagement
da geht's nach standorten ist dass ich
mir sorgen dass ich in zukunft hey wo er
sich schon geführt
tags darauf besuche ich feuer in seinem
büro ich will mit ihm über die kritik an
seiner arbeit reden nicht nur
stadträtinnen und stadträte nein auch
die eigenen mitarbeitenden werfen feurer
führungsschwäche und inkompetenz vor
zu beginn der dreharbeiten im
vergangenen oktober läuft diesbezüglich
gerade eine extra
eine untersuchung gegen ihn angeordnet
durch seine vier gemeinderats
kolleginnen und kollegen was deutlich
zeigt wie es um die kollegialität steht
ist allein auf weiter flur und steht
mächtig unter druck
wie interpretiert wenn ich nach links
über die burka ist nicht gut wenn ich
nach rechts über den berg ist nicht gut
das war sturm möglichkeit der grob top
ist noch richtig zu machen
wir müssen das gespräch unterbrechen
ein geplanter termin sei dazwischen
gekommen feurer bespricht sich mit dem
direktionssekretär seinem einzigen
vertrauten hier nervosität ist spürbar
irgendetwas scheint im busch zu sein
gemeinsam verlassen die beiden das büro
[Musik]
wir bleiben ahnungslos zurück später
erfahre ich dass die untersuchung
möglicherweise fores einzigen
verbündeten den kopf kosten könnte auf
die gründe dürfe nicht eingehen
man habe ihm diesbezüglich einen
maulkorb verpasst es ist deutlich
spürbar teurer ist aufs äußerste
angespannt
honig aus der fröhlich aus
verantwortlicher vorstellt aus
politischen überlegungen ja sage
zusammen ein prozess von rehn ablösung
ist die leute mir nach hitze sogar die
frage stellen auch noch sondern auch
konsequenzen
das heißt das wird also im moment
wirklich gedanken kommen dazu galt es
ist wirklich für - szenario nicht mehr
glück gelangen kann
grüße euch ganz herzlich zu der trotz
anspannung feurer leitet an diesem abend
die generalversammlung der gsvp 110
mitglieder seines gerade mal sieben sind
gekommen
mir scheint voller kämpft an
verschiedenen fronten um akzeptanz auch
aus homosexueller in der eigenen partei
die partei die partei das seriös
einstimmt und die sense soll wie sie
politisch malik
von bundesseite verstehen wie man sich
den pieks camping krieg an oster kasimir
stretchlimousinen ohne alternative der
gay pride mitfahrer sie los
das ist bisher nicht nur combo stück
sind nach dem schluss diese aktion hätte
ich allerdings gerne gesehen
ich erlebe feuer aus sehr kontrolliert
bestimmt hat es mit seiner funktion zu
tun
womöglich aber auch damit dass er ein
halbes leben lang versuchte seine
homosexualität zu verbergen
das ist die frage wieso jetzt so lange
ich glaube es ist dass ich nicht wieder
verstanden weiter aus schulen das
millionengrab italiener und die augen
ist für mich der beste falter vom in der
familie ab grenzwerte die ssg in
frankreich sehe dass ich es nie
geschafft hat über den märkten
vielleicht unsicherheit ist es wirklich
wichtig und dass das sehr schwierig die
frage sei aber nicht richtig sicher ist
das aber richtig
der grund für feuers hadern liegt hier
gottesdienst der christlichen freikirche
yahoo 30 jahre lang bewährt feurer ein
vollwertiges mitglied bis er sich als
schwul outete
daraufhin habe man ihn verstoßen
wertvoller aber ist geblieben seine
anwesenheit wird mittlerweile geduldet
es ist eine fräse ansicht so dass
homosexualität als krankhaft verhalten
hieß tour für das verhalten wo muss ich
hatte vor therapieren und ich habe
einiges gutmachen wenn ich sage was ich
glaube dass ich hier wird auf großer
widerstand gibt es aufnahmen auf großes
unverständnis stoßen desto mehr stürze
dass sie weiterhin in der gemeinschaft
land bleiben
es ist sicherlich ganz einfacher weg sie
also gerade am anfang nicht den alltag
macht hat eine mikro führenden verloren
führende wo niki mit der regentschaft
hat leider keiner was wirtschaft wachse
sie das ist zerbrochen
wenn alle homosexuelle fromann co2
ausstoßen abgrenzen und nähmaschine wie
es ist sagt iris und je mehr mit der
frage auseinandersetzen was heißt das
eigentlich bleiben ist das in jedem fall
stärker
diese frage stellt sich auch hier an der
pressekonferenz zum untersuchungsbericht
hatte mir gegenüber im vorfeld noch in
erwägung gezogen zu gehen bleibt er
jetzt trotz niederschmetterndem bericht
ist aber bestürzt dass der bericht
gravierende führungsmängel auf der
leitungsebene der direktion soziales und
sicherheit auf gezeigt habt die nicht
eigenständig erkannt und behoben worden
sind
er bedauert dass dies nur wir diesen
bericht erhält oder gestellt werden
musste das ärgste gegenspielerin muss
gehen aber auch sein enger vertrauter
ist weg gemeinderatskollegen steiger und
stadtpräsident fair werden ihnen zur
seite gestellt zur unterstützung man
könnte auch sagen bevormundung zu den
happigen vorwürfen darf sich voller
nicht äußern
dabei würde er sich dass es
offensichtlich gerne verteidigen wollen
er hofft auf unterstützung seiner
ratskollegin ein zweiter versuch diesmal
beim stadtpräsidenten doch die ansage
ist klar keine wertenden aussagen
höchstens eine zusammenfassung des
bereits gesagten betreut das miteinander
hoffe dass das die zukunft nur gute frau
sie und das ist die form mit einer
maßnahme erhöht die präsentierte wenige
wenig hemmen das motto die stimme im
moment trat vom rücktritt nicht im
vordergrund dass die offizielle
erklärung aber was ist der wahre grund
für sein bleiben auch ich bekomme keine
antwort klar es geht auch um prestige
und geld trotzdem
man muss eine solche ablehnung aushalten
können bei feuer scheint dies der fall
wie kommt das eine woche nach der
pressekonferenz treffe ich mich noch
einmal mit teurer
ob nun mobbing oder unfähigkeit so oder
so woher kommt diese ausdauer trotz
widerstand durchzuhalten und was aber
setzte im verlauf von filmen gefallen
ist ich dass sie immer wieder stationen
geht ihrem lover muss er nicht unbedingt
willkommen sind und sie bleiben trotzdem
warum
ja wenn minister so überlegt ein gerät
das ganze ja schon aus ganz fliesen sind
erlaubt wie das ist muss aber gar keine
wahl hat ps aus 2 allgemeines jahr lang
haben die mutter mit für die frage was
sie denn die hand das sie ja dass er
meine mutter hat damit für bernd
höchstem maße also das stört eigentlich
fast schon so gegangen
im spiel tauchte bedeutet wenn ich
größte aufgabe super lap oder nicht das
ist ganz
schwierige geschichte sehr sehr schwere
verletzung was für ein leben mit sich
gebracht und die füchse
damit habe ich nicht gerechnet wir reden
weiter über die psychischen probleme der
mutter ihren selbstmord das aufwachsen
bei vater und stiefmutter feuer sieht
darin eine mögliche antwort auf meine
frage warum jemand trotz schmach und
vernetzung aus hard und bleibt das habe
ich gleich dass es situationen gibt wo
man muss hart wenn wir das wort wieder
strom was von aviva hat und ich glaube
dass sie sich wirklich im islam berliner
gehört genügt mir diese erklärung ich
weiß es nicht
der konflikt mit seinen
regierungskollegen hat sich noch einmal
zugespitzt
wer teurer bleibt weiterhin
[Musik]